PROFESSOR: So we're
finally ready to tie up
these ideas about
mapping properties
to counting properties.
And let's begin with
the remark we already
made, that if there's a
bijection from one set
to another, if there's a
bijection from a finite set
A to a finite set B, then
A and B have the same size.
By the way, those vertical
bars, absolute value
of A, when it's a set
refers us to the size
of the set for finite sets.
So it means if A has n elements,
then the absolute value of A
is n.
OK.
Let's use this bijection
idea immediately.
Here's a nice example.
Suppose you want to figure
out how many subsets
are there of a finite set A?
Suppose you didn't know yet.
All right.
So what we're asking
about is, what's
the size of the power set of A?
Remember the power
set of A is all
of the possible subsets
of the set A. Well suppose
A has three elements.
What is the power
set of A look like?
If capital A has
elements little a,b,c.
It's a set of size three.
Then the power set
of A is going to have
one subset with no elements,
three subsets with one element,
they're listed there.
It's going to have three more
subsets with two elements,
and one subset with
three elements.
For a total of eight subsets
in the power set of A.
So let's see what the counting
argument in general would be.
So suppose that
A has n elements.
And we'll number them from
a 0 up through a n minus 1,
because computer scientists
usually zero origin index.
So A is a set of n
elements, indicated there.
Suppose I have some arbitrary
subset of A. Let's suppose
that it has a 0,
then there's no a 1,
that's what this space is for.
It has a 2.
It has a 3.
Doesn't have a 4.
And it goes on for awhile
in some uncertain way.
And it ends it actually
has the last element a
and minus 1 in it.
Well I can take the
subset like this
and have it correspond
to a bit-string,
where I put a 1 where the
element is there in the subset,
and a 0 where the element
is not there in the subset.
So there's a 1 because a 0 is
in the subset followed by a 0,
because a 1 is not in the
subset, followed by two 1's
because a 2 and a 3 are in
the subset, followed by a 0
because a 4 is not, and
so on, ending with a 1,
because a n minus
1 is in the subset.
So in short, the bit-string the
[? case ?] bit in the string
is 1, if and only if,
a sub k is in the set.
Now this clearly
defines a bijection
between subsets and strings.
Because given a subset, I can
uniquely determine the string,
and given the string, I can
uniquely determine the subset.
So there's one arrow
in and one arrow out
of each of those things.
So I could immediately conclude
then by this bijection theorem
that the number of
n bit-strings is
equal to the size of the
power set of A. Well,
now every computer
scientist knows how many
n bit-strings there are, right?
There are 2 to the
n n-bit bit-strings.
And therefore, the power set
of A has 2 to the n elements.
We can get rid of the n
because it was the size of A.
We have this nice formula.
The power set-- the size of
the power set of a finite set A
is 2 to the size of A. Well
there are some more counting
rules like the
bijection rule that
relates sizes of
sets by inequalities
according to whether
the mappings are
surjective injective
functions and so on.
So let's take a
quick look at those.
Suppose that I have a
surjective function from A
to B. Well that means there's
less than or equal to 1
arrow out of every element of
A, that's what function means.
And there is greater
than or equal to 1 arrow
in to every element of B.
That's what surjective means.
So here's this function from
A to B. That means less than
or equal to 1 arrow out.
And that means that there
have to be more elements in A
than there are
arrows since there's
at most, one arrow out
of every element of A
and that accounts
for all the arrows.
So the size of A has
to be greater than
or equal to the
number of arrows when
you have a partial function.
When it's a surjection,
that means that there's
an arrow coming into
every element of B.
That means that there have
to be at least as many arrows
as there are in B.
Because everything in B
has at least one
arrow coming in.
So if you look at these
two pieces, the size of A
has to be greater than or
equal to the number of arrows.
And the size of B
has to be less than
or equal to the
number of arrows.
Putting them together,
we have the mapping rule
for surjections.
If I have a surjective
function from A to B
it means the size
of A is greater than
or equal to the size of
B for finite A and B.
The same argument
goes for injections.
With an injection, I have less
than or equal to 1 arrow in.
And what does that tell me?
Well if it's total, then
there's at least 1 arrow out
of everything.
And that means that the size
of A has to be less than
or equal to the
number of arrows.
Because every element
in A contributes
an arrow, maybe more than one.
OK.
If it's an injection,
there's less
than or equal to 1 arrow
coming into each element of B.
That means that B had
better be big enough
to catch all the arrows.
So the number of
arrows has to be
less than or equal
to the size of B.
Put those two
inequalities together
and you find that if you have a
total injective relation from A
to B, that implies
that the size of A
is less than or equal to the
size of B for finite A and B.
The statement here that it's
a totally injective relation
is for generality.
But the truth is,
whenever there's
a total injective
relation there's also
a totally injective function.
I'll leave that to a class
exercise to work out.
So to summarize,
what we can do is
characterize these kinds of
jection relations between sets.
So let's define A
bij B. So this is
going to be a binary
relation between two
sets A and B. And its meaning is
that there's a bijection from A
to B. So the definition of
bij is a binary relation where
the domain and the co domain
are the class of finite sets
or all sets for that matter.
surj B, A surj B
means that there
is a surjective function
from A to B. Again,
surj is a binary
relation between sets.
And finally, A inj
B says, there's
a total injection
relation from A to B.
So we have those three
relations between sets.
And what we've just
shown is that if there's
a bijection between
A and B, that's true,
implies that the size of A
is equal to the size of B.
And in fact, it's not hard
to prove the converse.
If the size of A and the
size of B are the same,
then it's easy enough to find
a bijection between them.
Similarly, if there's a
surjection from A to B,
that's true, if and
only if, the size of A
is greater than or
equal to the size of B.
And if there's an
injection from A to B,
that's true, if and
only if, the size of A
is less than or equal
to the size of B.
So this-- the existence of these
kinds of relations between sets
is a handle on their
relative sizes.
And this applies for
finite sets A and B.
Because we really know what
the size of infinite sets are.
So it wouldn't make sense
to talk about the mapping
Lemma for infinite sets.
However, we can ask some
questions about infinite sets.
So one natural question
to ask is, let's look
at some finite properties.
If the size of A and B are the
same and the size of B and C
are the same, obviously, the
size of A and C are the same.
And that corresponds
directly to an insertion
about bij because the size
of A equals the size of B,
for finite sets, is
the same as A bij B.
So what this says is
that if A bij B and B
bij C, then A bij C. If
there's a bijection from A to B
and a bijection from
B to C, then there's
a bijection from A to C.
Corresponding property
for finite sets, again, is
greater than or equal to-- if A
is greater than or equal to
B greater than or equal to C,
then A is-- the
size of A is greater
than or equal to the size of
C. And that would correspond
to a similar statement about
the surjection relation,
A surj B, B surj C,
implies A surj C.
And finally, more
interesting one,
is that if A and B
are each greater than
or equal to each other, if A
is greater than or equal to
B and B-- the size of B is
greater than or equal to A,
then in fact, they're
the same size.
A is equal to B.
That would correspond
to the following statement
in terms of jections,
if A surj B and B surj A, then
A bij B. Now all of these facts
follow immediately for
finite sets A and B.
But we're going to be
interested in whether they
hold for infinite sets.
So they follow immediately for
finite sets from the Mapping
Lemma because the Mapping Lemma
says that these bij and surj
relations are the same
is equal and greater
than or equal to [INAUDIBLE].
So again, this is immediate
from the Mapping Lemma.
But now I can ask whether
or not these same properties
hold for infinite sets.
It's an exercise in
reasoning about properties
of mappings and relations.
And the answer is that the first
two claims go through easily
if you're trying to prove
them for finite sets,
for infinite sets,
the basic ideas.
Let's look at the first one.
It says that if A-- If there's
a bijection from A to B
and there's a
bijection from B to C,
then there ought to be one from
A to C. How do you find it?
Well it's actually easy.
You just compose
the bijection from A
to B with the
bijection from B to C.
And it's a very easy
exercise that the composition
of bijection is a bijection.
Likewise, the composition of
surjections is a surjection.
And that proves the
second claim easily.
But the third claim is much more
interesting and is not obvious.
It's called the
Schroeder-Bernstein theorem.
And it will come up a little
bit in a few more lectures.